foreign
[Music]
it's nice to see you're still here I
hope you really enjoyed the three days
of conference and today I'm here with
Vlad we're both a product manager on
Google Cloud conversational Ai and we're
going to introduce you to the new
features that we are launching as part
of vertex AI search and conversation
um so we'll go to you know some
background on generative Ai and then
we'll do some live demos to show you all
these new features and we will have two
special guests Peter from ING and Omar
from Six Flags that will share with you
uh their stories and how they use the
generative AI features from Google
clouds to achieve their own goals
and now I will uh passage to vlads to
give you the intro
thank you so much
uh so hi I'm Vlad
um I had a chance to work in
conversational AI since several years
starting with the Google assistant in
2016 and I wanted to start this talk
with you know my personal kind of
experience in how during these just few
years we totally changed the approach in
how we build conversational AI
so when we launched oops the other way
when we launched the Google assistant in
2016 you know like a lot of the
production real production systems are
actually based on what the today could
call prehistoric nlu basically we had uh
you know grammars written by you know
very expensive resources so those were
linguists with phds who could also write
code and who you know who would write
grammars who can encode the you know the
language rules uh to kind of figure out
the user intent and it was like really
not scalable we had one of these
resources per language was slow and not
skilled in the meantime
so the research Community has been
trying to solve uh you know this with
deep learning right and the first
winning approaches were basically to
transform uh words into embeddings into
vectors pass them into the deeper neural
networks and then you know transform
into something for example other words
or you know some labels right and if we
wanted to run full sentences through
these models we have systems like
recurrent neural networks where it would
basically pass one a word at a time to
these models
and uh and then basically you know again
transform into other sentences or other
labels and while the systems you know
had some initial success they actually
had two huge problems they were very
slow because of the kind of the nature
of running them uh sequentially and then
also they were like very poor Learners
uh they suffer problems like Vanishing
gradients where we're trying to kind of
teach them a lot of data and then
literally you know everything changed
overnight uh when this paper was
published this was in 2017 by a bunch of
googlers uh that introduced you know the
Transformer architecture and the
transform architecture had like really
several almost magical properties like
incredible properties right first of all
uh um this model like was super
expressive it could express many
possible algorithms very efficiently
then it was like a incredibly good
learner it could learn really well from
a lot of data and then lastly it kind of
process information in parallel and it
allows us to kind of run it super
efficiently on the on the best hardware
that we have right so we basically
achieved like orders of magnitude of
improvement in terms of computation
and uh you know it was like such an
impact uh this paper it was selected by
Nature as the fourth most uh kind of
impactful paper over the whole science
you know on the span for 15 to 20.
um and you know if we look in the past
three years what happened after that
actually that might have been an
understatement
um so the next kind of huge Improvement
came just the the the the the year after
again in Google with Bert uh where
basically the birth researchers figured
out that instead of using the usual
machine learning methods where we would
kind of prepare a bunch of training data
and then train the system right we
actually could use is the systems
process text like large acts of text to
produce text we actually could use a
trick and then like use any article you
know on Wikipedia or any piece of text
and just pretend that we don't know a
certain word right and then we say hey
model try to guess this word but the
reality we do know the word we know the
original text so we can actually use it
to then tweak the model parameters right
and using this trick we could then you
know teach you know these models with
basically the whole human knowledge once
we had you know scale enough parameters
and this was like hugely impactful a
couple of things you kind of came out of
that like one is that you know when we
were pre-training this this large models
with so much data they ended up being
extremely useful out of the box right so
these parameters that we use after
pre-training were actually you know very
useful per se
and not only that but actually we figure
out that you can use them as a starting
point to train Downstream to fine-tune
Downstream your further systems right so
these were like the two like I think
really the two biggest Innovations uh
that came out uh over these two years in
Google
um and then you know that those two
innovations gave us like some
capabilities that were like totally
elusive to our community you know trying
to build conversational applications in
the years in the years previous to that
so in particular uh you know the
transform architecture finally you know
and the way it's trained kind of finally
could really understand context right
like understand sentences understand
sequence of sentences that was very very
hard to do before also it could generate
a predict content and for the way it was
trained you know it could actually
capture a lot of the World Knowledge and
actually even some common sense
and if we go like one step further
you know once you can understand context
and text and you can produce and answer
something appropriately you can actually
do human dialogue right and then the
other thing is that you know because of
the nature of kind of generating and
predicting content with some new tricks
to the edit of how we train these models
like you know chain of thoughts and
things like that we were able to
increasingly create models that not only
can you know understand and predict but
can also actually solve problems
um
so now if you think about it like you
know if we have like a commodity a
component that can do dialogue and we
are able to creatively solve problems
those are really the key ingredients to
create a really capable assistant that
can help through conversation users to
achieve their goals right
um and this is like you know like all of
these properties are fully new like we
were trying to to get to something like
that for many years there was like you
know in a very very hard suddenly we had
you know all of that increasingly over
time over the past years
however before we can you know really
run this uh you know um properties and
use them in real production systems with
real users we had to solve some
additional problems so we you know we
these models are predictive engines so
sometimes they make up information if
you just use them out of the box without
additional you know systems around them
uh you know it's easy to kind of easier
to get really good quality with you know
like huge uh models but sometimes it's
not practical because you want some
constant latency as well uh you know
that you can afford and then on the
developer experience side you know
developers want more control then just
don't want just a black box they throw
everything out you know on and then they
just hope for the best they want more
control also they want the ability to
kind of handle complexity and
scalability once they start adding a lot
of use cases that you know these agents
needs to do they don't want this but
it's just cases to can interfere with
each other right but to scale uh well
and then they want the ability to kind
of you know to be able to fix problems
where they identify a problem they want
to be able to fix it to fix a whole
family so problems so next time the
system is better right the school is
gonna hill climbing and then obviously
you know this your system as well uh you
know had uh had to kind of respect
privacy security compliance right
um so basically uh you know what our
goal is our goal is to give everybody
together Enterprises around the world a
platform that is safe uh compliant and
guarantees uh you know that your data
stays that's still yours right that
gives you the ability to very easily you
know in few steps create very powerful
uh conversational applications but also
gives you the ability to then tune it
and kind of customize it where you want
or need right so this is why this is
what we are building with the
conversational AI in vertex AI
um giving you systems that are able to
you know answer complex queries by
transferring it from your data and
grounding in your data able to generate
additional content from its knowledge or
starting from your data and then
transforming it further right but also
able to kind of you know go and complete
tasks on behalf of the user and transact
to your you know using your API to your
systems
um
so how do we do that we do that by
basically building the full platform
right in several layers on top of each
other right so we start with the Google
Cloud infrastructure on top of that you
have the model Garden where you get
access to the best Google models and the
best open source models then we have the
AI layer the vertex a platform layer
that allows you to you know to tune and
distill these models and kind of make
them like even more customized to your
needs and your Enterprises on top of
that we are adding a layer that allows
you to really connect to your systems
right so the first is data connectors uh
that basically allow us allow you to
kind of connect the agents to your data
to your websites to your documents to
your you know databases and so on and so
that basically the agent is able to
search in real time and get the data
necessary you know to continue the
conversation and ask you other questions
we are adding extensions as you have
seen in the keynote we're basically uh
now you can also uh you know kind of uh
use the agent to communicate with your
apis and with your systems right and
then grounding super important because
you want these systems to be grounded in
your data in a factual and on top of
that we are adding the conversational AI
layer right it allows you to build this
conversational applications and also
like some features uh where where you
can put the control that you want as you
see you will see in a moment
okay so here is basically like one
example of how you can build an
application in three easy steps right
some new features that we are bringing
um so the first one you just connected
your data right so basically you can
connect with documents like your whole
domain uh you know your websites that
you want or some other systems as we
said before uh like uh you know some
databases that you have or you know
third-party systems like jira conference
or whatever whatever you have right and
then suddenly like almost out of the box
you have a bot or an agent that is able
to uh query all of this data search for
uh you know for the relevant parts of
the data real time get it back to the
agent of the model right and then answer
appropriately to the user questions then
next you can add extensions it will
configure the existing one so you can
add your own so the system the the
larger image model can suddenly talk to
your apis right
um and the last thing is a new feature
that we are introducing to allow you to
have control over how certain tasks and
subtasks are executed this is very
important
um basically like we are interested in
this feature where you can specify step
by step how you want certain tasks to be
executed so now Solan will show us how
that works in practice thank you
everyone
so if you attended the keynote two days
ago you remember that Nisha had walked
you to the setup of a search app for the
DMV website so today we're going to do
it again but first a chat app
so let's see see how it works we are on
the app builder here I'm going to create
a new app
so this time
Vladimir I need
Okay cool so you just missed one screen
but now you see it
um we're going to choose the
conversation
app
so I'm going to give it a name the DMV
chatbot
I enter the name of my company State DMV
here I have a bunch of options to make
sure out of the box I get Knowledge from
my own data from the monad knowledge and
connection to the vertex AI extensions
now I have the skeleton of my app I can
do a few things first I want my chatbot
to be able to find answers within my own
data so I have a bunch of options I can
connect a website I can connect and
structure data from bigquery or Google
cloud storage and soon you will be able
also to connect
data from your own Services third party
services that you used internally such
as jira Salesforce to be able for
chatbot to find answers on this content
so here I'm going to
add the website
and what will happen under the hood is
like Enterprise search will Index this
website to be able for the large
language model to use the search results
to provide an answer
so now I I gave it some data I will also
you know enable the the default vertexa
extension so the bot can be smarter when
the bot accomplishes some tasks
and the last feature that I wanted to
show you in this Builder is this new
playbook feature where basically you can
describe
instructions in a natural language way
for the bird to be able to complete some
tasks
so you don't even need you know to cut
it you will just so here I will show you
an example for all the tasks related to
driver license
you just explain very simply what the
chatbot has to do which information they
have to ask and which API they have to
use to complete some actions
so now let's see
see it in action how it works on my
website so I added the chatbot on the
DMV website
I going to ask the chatbed to somehow to
renew my
license
to the boat understands my request
asking me if anything has changed Yes
actually I moved
okay now it's telling me that I need
actually to book an appointment and
asking me where I want to go
so I live in Los Gatos
so now the body is going to chat to
check on the DMV internal resources for
availability so that's what I described
in the Playbook
and it's like suggesting a few
appointments I'm going to choose the 230
and then we're going to call different
extensions for the board to be able to
create an event in my Gallant calendar I
generate a summary with the llm and send
an email to my Gmail account so I can
not forget this appointment
I'm all set so you've seen like uh one
aspect of this chatbot I'm going to show
you a second one because this time I
want to actually find a bit more
um information uh that will be found on
the website so for instance I don't know
if I actually do I need
a motto
cycling license
for my Vespa
so this is you know infoseking queries
the boat is going to look on the website
for an answer because I previously
ingested this website
and now the body is also going to
automatically uh give me an answer so a
quick summary with a link with a
citation of where you know this
information was found on the website and
also here I got super cool interaction
where I'm redirecting on the right page
so I can verify the information
so actually I don't know the side of the
engine but I know that I have a
primavera
Vespa
so now they both understand the context
of the conversation that I'm still
asking about my Vespa but I have
Primavera and the boat in that situation
couldn't find the information directly
on the website so the board was looking
for information on the llm
self-knowledge and provide me with some
information about different uh Primavera
Vista
so that's it and I think we all agree
that this is you know both as a bot
Builder and as an end user the
experience that we want to have and this
is now possible with the new vertex AI
search and conversation
Quebec
[Applause]
okay so in case you are a dialogflow
user and you're wondering you know what
is what is happening with our course we
are bringing all of these features also
to dialogflow and you can basically
extend your existing Bots and ages that
you have there with using these features
so then we'll do them on that or build
new Bots merging the best of the of the
of Both Worlds you know we have like the
full control of dialogflow and then also
certain parts that you can design in the
generative way uh so so then we'll go
through that we are adding these three
new features answer from content
generator responses and playbooks and I
think it's best to see it in action
directly so please join thank you so can
we switch to the demo
thank you so you know as a new product
manager for all these features and
direct flow when we launched them in
preview two months ago I was inundated
with feature requests uh questions from
customer Engineers but of course so I
wanted to build a bot that helped me to
manage all this like volume of queries
and so I built Felix with all this new
feature and today I'm going to show you
both how Felix helped me to do this and
also how we built Phyllis Felix with the
genetic features on the workflow
so let's start with something you know
just easy hi there
so now I get this you know answer which
is actually a response that I uh wrote
on Direct flow so this no llm this is
kind of you know the way the old way of
building a boat where based on some
training phrases you get a response so
you can see that this is the exact
response here
so now if I go a bit you know outside of
this training phrases and I say hi there
my name
is Celine
I'll get a different answer but Felix is
even telling me hi Celine this is not
the same respawn this is like a response
generated by dlnm because for this
feature
I
I just use opt-in for the generative
fallback
here you will see it I just obtained for
generative fallback which means that if
it goes outside of the training phrases
we'll let the llm generate a nice and
contextual answer
so now let's see how actually Felix can
help me to for customer Engineers to
find answers under the general Builder
so how
to build
chatbots
with app builder
foreign
so now Felix is giving me a summary of
the instructions to build a chatbot that
you can see here just in a few steps as
well as a link which is again the
citation that was used to generate the
answer so I have a granted answer based
on my own data and how did I do this in
dialog flow I just connected to like the
data star feature my own website that
was you know ingested the same way that
we did it for the DMV website I did it
here for this documentation website
so this is super easy this comes just
out of the box
now I want Felix to do even more can you
write codes
great Felix can even write code so what
about you write code to upload files
to a Google storage packets
cool Felix is like giving me the exact
codes to do this
why how does it work
so I use the generator features which is
a new feature on dialogflow
which basically will be triggered by
a fulfillment and here you can see that
I just wrote a simple prompt that tllm
will use every time I say write code
with a few parameter to make sure that
the llm knows about the context of the
conversation
that's the generator feature super cool
right
and now I will show you the last feature
which is basically what we showed
previously with the Playbook that you
can also do on dialogflow so you know I
wanted to also make sure that Felix can
help me to manage all the feature
requests and create ticket directly on
our own system
so I wrote a simple Playbook
to capture all the feature requests so I
didn't do I didn't need to code anything
I just write a list of instructions with
the parameters and how to connect it to
our own system
and now let's see how it works so I want
to file a feature requests
so then Felix will follow this list of
instructions asking me what the name of
the feature requests comparison table
I want actually the llm to generate
table to compare products
excuse me why this is critical because
TMV customer
needs it now
and then asking me about my
email address and now the feature
request will be sent directly to our
internal system we'll still have to
privatize the request and make sure we
implement it but this really helped me
to kind of gain productivity so you can
do all of this with now the app builder
and dialogflow
[Applause]
okay
so so far we talked only about chat
experiences but conversational AI is
more than that it's also about voice
right and even more than just voice so
Google has been investing in voice
experiences since many years
and in particular voice basically mean
two things misunderstanding when
somebody's speaking and then being able
to produce you know human-like voices on
the other end uh so in terms of
understanding uh the users we have the
newest USM models that can understand uh
transcribe hundreds of languages and
also uh Google is investing this project
to actually go way beyond that and
there's thousands of languages in
actually like a superhuman way because
it understands the you know the like
even in noisy environments across like
so many languages right
um in terms of uh kind of language
production so once we have kind of like
the answer from the agent in text we
want to say to the user in a voice that
is sounding As Natural as possible so
this is also like a something very
important where we have been investing a
lot and let me show you a couple of
improvements so one of the features that
we have is
basically the ability uh you know to
kind of create a custom voice so we just
need a few minutes of a recording of an
actor and then we can create a voice
that is identical to that of the actor
that can say anything right so here's an
example so we have created uh we we
created a custom voice and then after
that we have a new sentence that wasn't
you know part of the training and we we
let it kind of read out what the bot and
the human and I want you to try to guess
which one is button which one is human
okay
ah it's there okay okay
everyone's strengths came together it
began with a broken Funk pattern from
the piano and the horns ran harmonized
chromatic lines through it
so this was the first one is the second
one
in New Amsterdam everyone's strengths
came together it began with a broken
bunk pattern from the piano and the
horns ran harmonized chromatic lines
through it what do you think which one
the one on the left one on the right so
who is for the one on the left
who is for the one on the right
that's half half so I need to be honest
I forgot
because we changed these light so many
times I I really forgot um
I I can figure it out with you know
headphones like when I really listen but
yeah anyway so this is this is one way
uh you know but it still to kind of
sound really natural right but on top of
that
um what you also want sometimes is to
kind of Infuse emotion that we want you
know into the language so here is a
couple of uh just examples of how we can
basically say something with different
emotions
um so this is like a casual voice that
you can say something right
account balances
um 92.50 this is like perfect kind of
you know like a board agent in a contact
center
this is like a more lively uh if I want
this great for marketing uh for example
this is a very exciting time to be
working on artificial intelligence right
um or you know if you want something
more firm then you can use this however
it is important that we take our time to
make sure the work we are doing is safe
and ethical alternative right and my
favorite is the apologetic voice
unfortunately we can't give you any more
discounts yeah
[Applause]
yeah
so uh exactly um so I'll skip actually
uh in order to make time so the um oops
the other the other kind of feature you
know is like voice is great but
sometimes it's really really hard to get
everything via voice like there's
certain information there's just like so
much easier to either input or
understand if there is an image in
between right or there is an
architectural input interface so we're
launching as well uh call Companion
feature that basically is a companion to
the voice conversation uh with a user
and so then can uh play a video oh yeah
thank you yeah so we couldn't do it live
uh because of because the room so
we prepared the video for you
[Music]
hi I am the Google call Companion
insurance agent how can I help you
my car had a
an accident
I'm very sorry to hear that before we
continue is everyone safe
I'm relieved to hear that everyone is
all right would you like me to help you
file an insurance claim for the incident
yes
I would be happy to help let's get
started can you please enter the account
number for your insurance policy
thank you I was able to locate the
account the policy owner is listed as
Jane Smith the vehicle on record is a
2022 Futura Impreza there is a collision
liability limit of fifty thousand
dollars and a personal liability limit
of one hundred thousand dollars does
this sound correct yes
on what date did the incident occur
today
I will enter the date as the 30th of
August 2023. what was the city and state
where the incident occurred
thank you I will record the location as
San Francisco California did the
incident occur in your future Impreza
thank you for confirming this is the
first of three questions I'll need to
ask about the incident was this a single
car or multi-car accident
got it were there any passengers in your
car at the time no
finally were you issued a ticket on the
scene no I wasn't
can you please upload a photo of the
damage
photo received I appreciate your
patience during this process the claim
has been filed and you will be contacted
by a representative to follow up within
48 hours is there anything else I can
assist you with today no
thank you again for contacting us have a
great day
[Applause]
so this was an example of what you could
build it's called company including some
natural cues like them uh ability to use
both the visual interface as well as
wise
I think it's well done right so thank
you so much this was our part so now we
would like to invite our dear customers
too
um tell their experience using the
products
[Applause]
I'm Peter from ING I'm very excited to
be here I'll give a quick explanation
about why we do what we do in the
contact centers today and then a small
demo thank you on the initiatives that
we're taking together with Google so
within ing I think for the people who
don't know ing we're a bank with a
mostly European footprint we have about
37 million customers 10 retail countries
and then we're also active also Banking
and other activities uh we're active in
many different languages which is very
relevant for our our testimonial here
today as a bank we focus a lot on
providing a superior customer experience
making it fast personal easy and
relevant
we we are NPS we're the highest NPS and
five out of 10 retail markets and we're
investing a lot in that we also have
a very strict cost discipline there's a
bit of an echo am I the only one hearing
that
there's a very strict cost discipline in
the
in our operations and in our contact
centers we've set ourselves a goal to
reduce incoming contacts by 30 percent
by 2025. now how do we do that we have a
lot of focus on bringing Digital
Services through our mobile app
we do we promote chat as a preferred
Channel
um so there's a lot of chat automation
chat Bots happening there and uh for all
the human interactions of course we do
want to keep the emotional connection
with our customers it's very important
to us also towards that NPS again but we
want to do that in a scalable way and
there becoming language agnostic is
quite important to us so in terms of
transformation drivers that uh um that
are enabling that we see uh first time
right responses reducing on the training
time sometimes we're up to 20 percent of
agent time today that gets invested in
in training and we want to increase on
the quality and the consistency of the
advice and information that is given to
our customers
we have already pretty large chatbots
deployed in multiple countries we've
been working with dialogflow for more
than three years now so we were looking
for an Enterprise grade partner that
could indeed
allow us to scale rapidly across our
markets and we're doing that today
but what we've seen is that we're
hitting a certain Plateau we have Bots
that yeah fire out go uh yeah that go
above 1000 intense easily
um and so we're looking for new ways
that helps us to both increase
deflection rates with our Bots but at
the same time
enable us to speed up deployment of bots
when we enter into new markets
and then the third one it's what I just
mentioned we do want to make sure that
when we are contacting customers that we
can do that in a language agnostic way
because that way we can scale our
contact centers across the globe if one
in Belgium is occupied and someone from
the Netherlands or elsewhere can take
over
now
getting to the gist of it what are we
doing today there's a lot of things
happening within ing but we focus a lot
on two initiatives the first one is the
agent assist so what happens is there is
a a chat agent that gets support
from a tool that tool listens in to the
chat
the chat agent injects a query into the
agent assist tooling and then gets the
response I'll quickly show how it works
so what happens is the chat agent
chooses the language injects the
question
and then we have a couple of knowledge
bases in there those go from web pages
to training material to other types of
templates
and then every time we have the URL we
have the reference to where what
document is it found
and we actually monitor two things so
you see at the right hand side
you saw two things you saw one did we
find the correct resource and two was
the answer that was generated the
correct answer so meaning was it useful
were you able to inject it back into the
chat towards the customer
today we have so we're live with that
and
um
we're we're improving performance as we
go so we were at 36 on Leverage
um we're way up on web pages we're way
down on PDFs but we're in the midst of
fixing that so now we're at 50 percent
where we can just do like the generated
response and inject it back
um yeah and we're striving to be by the
4th of October that's my birthday uh on
the level of 90 that's the objective
that we've set out for ourselves
and we're confident that we will make
that happen as well so this is uh this
is where we are today there's a couple
of improvements that we want to have we
want to make it as we said language
agnostic so French operator Dutch
customer that we can fulfill that
Journey uh with some translation is it
llm is it the the Google Translate in
between we're playing with that as we
speak we want to make sure that we
generate an answer out of all the
different knowledge bases into one
answer and there's a couple of
improvements that we're working on
together with Google and we're very much
looking forward to to those and then
very quickly because I only have five
minutes but I could probably talk about
this one for for an hour is that we're
also fully testing now in sandbox our
generative AI chatbot
this one is launched in the Dutch Market
and uh or will be launched in the Dutch
Market as soon as we are confident um so
it's clearly mentioned here within risk
appetite we're a bank so we have 13
factors against which we're currently
um constantly evaluating continuously
improving our guardrail mapping we have
llms testing
a second llm testing against
hallucination we we have llms checking
don't we give any advice around
Investments which we're not allowed to
do through these channels uh is the
right tone of voice there
etc etc so we're um we're making big
steps there it looks very promising we
haven't launched just yet but we're
we're quite close
hold on so with that I'll hand over to
Omar from six tracks thank you
[Applause]
all right thank you everybody for for
your time
um my name is Omar Omron I'm the chief
digital officer for Six Flags
and before starting I want to thank the
Six Flags team Jody Patrick Steve a lot
of the people who worked really hard to
make what I'm about to talk about happen
and I also want to thank the Google team
Lionel cam Aaron so many great people
who made this happen and also a company
called Feud who helped design the front
end also of the conversation AI chatbot
now Six Flags
is a fun company so let's have some fun
thank you very much
[Music]
let's go
all right who likes roller coasters here
raise your hands
that's amazing it's almost everybody so
let's put some numbers about what Six
Flags is
Six Flags is the largest regional theme
parks with 27 Parks spread in North
America and is the largest water park
operator also in the world we have more
than 20 million visitors that come to
our Park every year
70 of them are in six hour driving
distance to one of the parks
and then we have also many parks with
beautiful animals and one interesting
fact that you might not know Six Flags
has the biggest Safari outside of Africa
and it's actually located in one of our
parks in New Jersey
now whenever you
talk about digital transformation across
six lugs
it's actually more than just a website
or maybe an app
it's a it's all across Six Flags so from
the rise and roller coaster from your
experience at the at the right that will
change through digit transformation how
you visualize it how you experience it
how you listen to it the food and
beverage how you order food instead of
waiting in line from your app from a
kiosk
how you you enter actually the park
we're the first Park to now automate the
tall Plaza so just put your license
plate and then the toll plazas will
automatically open for you and you go in
so you wait much less to enter the parks
from parking security how you buy your
tickets it's it's all across
and
Six Flags has always been uh the com the
theme park with the best rise and
interaction
and right now we're very much posed to
also start leading on Innovation across
the industry
and in order to do this we need a
strategic partner to help us get there
so that's why we partnered we did a
strategic partnership with Google in
order to accelerate that
and whenever you're talking about
building the theme park of the future
elevating the guest experience that has
experience no longer start at the park
the cancer experience starts even before
coming to the park whenever you're
online exploring what you'd like to do
whenever you go to Six Flags buying your
ticket buying your season pass going to
social media getting an email getting an
SMS about six lakhs to entering the park
from again from your car into the tall
Plaza to find the right spot for you
scanning your ticket whenever you come
in
do getting a flash pass skipping the
lines ordering food ordering retail to
even when you leave the park getting
information more about how was your
visit
so the key behind it is we would like to
make this whole experience personalized
and in order to make it personalized
that's why we also with our strategic
partner with Google start using gen AI
for it
now I'll ask you one question
who likes to go sometimes to the same
restaurant because you know the host or
the waiter and they always take care of
you because they know your preferences
raise your hand
that's exactly it and that's the
opportunity that is in front of you
that's the opportunity that we're also
working with Google on it in order to
cut to make the whole uh experience at
the park completely personalized from
online whenever you're shopping we ask
you for your preference and then we
start tailoring the whole experience for
you before you go and then when you come
to the park we're able to navigate you
take you to the restaurants where you
like the most where you don't have
allergy to and the best roller coaster
that you would like to enjoy or Family
Rides
and what's right now we're doing with
Google is the website and the app we're
both building uh a chatbot powered by
gen AI in order to be able to live the
guest experience and I don't know about
the 30 maybe it's uh what Pierce said
same to us we're going to be able to
automate 30 of all the questions that
guests will usually ask us online
and what's a very important for us as
well is that the data is grounded within
six lags because we want to always uh
make sure that the guest information is
well protected and being able to use
natural language
the chatbot that we used to have used to
take us months and months and months to
be able to develop and create all those
different use cases and now with a
matter of weeks we're able to actually
have a much better experience and answer
most of the questions the guests would
ask
now
one more thing we're working on that
we're going to be unveiling soon is also
how can take the personalization to a
much higher level by mixing the digital
and the physical Reams together in order
to have a much personalized experience
at the park and and that's something
that we're going to be releasing soon
that's very exciting my last message to
you is
forget about six likes to build anything
this is an amazing opportunity for you
this is the most exciting time right now
on technology so how can you boost your
career how can you boost your goals and
that's why we selected Google and and
their Cloud Technologies but most
importantly also whenever you start a
strategic partnership with a company you
want to see what values they have and
when we kicked off the meeting with
Google many many months ago about this
they start with their values which very
much aligned with six likes values so
that's very important because this is
not a one project this is a complete
journey in order to lead innovation in
the whole industry
every object around us has been created
by people who are not smarter but they
took the first initiative to go and make
it happen and this is what we're doing
here are Six Flags to lead on innovation
similar to The Way We LED on the best
rise and attractions and this is an
opportunity for all of you so thank you
and the best easier to come for
everybody thank you very much